what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today sorry my boyfriend's being
annoying
today get out of here today i am going
to be reacting
to mike tyson's savage moments
[Laughter]
baby i'm doing it oh my goodness okay
um before i start [ __ ] sit down
before i begin do not forget to like
comment and subscribe
the best way to support the channel is
to subscribe
and let me know in the comments what
your favorite mike tyson moment
is okay
confusion with mike tyson who's standing
by with jim gray jim
yeah okay thank you steve mike was that
your shortest fight ever
i've been witness there's only one guard
and mohammed blessings and peace be upon
him as his prophet
i dedicate this fight to my brother
daryl brown who died
i'll be there to see you i love you with
all my heart can you answer the question
to my children i love you oh god oh man
what is this your shortest fight ever in
any time amateur professional ever
assalamualaikum maida um
i don't know man yeah yeah linux lewis
linux i'm coming for you mike is it
frustrating to train
like you did and then have this in seven
or eight seconds i only trained probably
two weeks or three weeks for this fight
i had to bury my best friend
and i dedicated this fight i wasn't
gonna fight i dedicated this fight to
him
i was gonna rip his heart out i'm the
best ever i'm the most brutal and
vicious and most ruthless champion has
ever been
there's no one can stop me lynx is a
conqueror no i'm alexander he's no
alexander
i'm the best ever there's never been
anybody i'm sonny liston i'm jack
dempsey there's no one like me i'm from
their club there's no one that can match
me
my style is impetuous my defense is
impregnable
and i'm just ferocious i want your heart
i want to eat his children
praise be to allah are you saying now
mike the bike
what on earth we're talking about
greater than our leaders
he's very delusional he can't listen um
if he if he was anywhere near that um
that realm of grand island he'd be able
to take his kids to school by himself
[Music]
okay he can't take he can't take his kid
to school by himself and he talked about
he's great
greatness is not guarding yourself from
the people greatness
i have no idea who he's talking about
being accepted by the people
he can't take his kids alone to to
school by himself
he's a little scared man he's a very
small scared man
i'm just i'm just looking forward for
the win if douglas beats holyfield
it looks as though you've got a rematch
with buster
some people think you'll stiff alex
stewart and not
fight him in december no she shouldn't
believe that at all because know why
because after because after i i've
kicked stuart ass
and gave him a slow beating nearly death
i'm going to take whoever's the one
after that the holyfield douglas fight
and then regain my title and hopefully i
can fight raider ruddock or this other
guy
george foreman before he dies you know i
mean gregor mortis
mike you you know that is a tough man
a tough man seem to be incensed about
criticism that you've received what
you're feeling about the criticism these
guys never fought in a damn life and
still they're going to be
um then psychologists and say i
i'm a squam swami and i could look at
mike tyson's brain and
tell by the way he's acting this is what
he's thinking which is
you know i mean and the um donut is
unbelievable is that the public believes
this
you know what i mean and they believe
this and i think i mean these guys are
idiots
i mean they never fought a day in their
life and then these things got to talk
about me and television
like i'm building more and i don't see
what i don't see them on totally people
don't tell me
they say hey mike how you doing you're
looking great shape you look good man
boy you would man please man have to get
my face in mikey i think you're
individual they can't say i'm a bum i'm
not a good fighter because you know i
mean
three and a half years and 11 defenses
proved it you know they can't say that
so they could say mike you're a hell of
a fighter but i think you're a dog i
think i hate you
i hate what you stand for you know what
i mean whatever let me have the guts to
say that
then i got caught up in another piece of
[ __ ] don king who's a wretched this is
just a
wretched slimy reptilian [ __ ]
right
um this is supposed to be my this
supposed to be my brother i have a
really hard time
understanding him like i have no idea
what he's saying
my black brother right he's just um he's
just a bad man he's real bad man
he abused you and he would throw he
would he would he would kill his mother
for a dollar
his ruthless he's on he's deplorable he
doesn't know how to love anybody
that's just the way he is the greatest
country in the world man this is america
baby
put your mother in the streets jackie
your punk ass white boy
come here and tell me if i [ __ ] you in
your ass you punk white boy
your [ __ ] you can't touch me you're
not man enough i eat y'all
alive you [ __ ] what
what on earth oh
[ __ ] ass for that everybody you [ __ ]
come on you [ __ ]
you're scared coward you got man enough
to [ __ ] with me that is a heart
who lives in my world [ __ ] look at you
scared now
damn scared like a little white [ __ ]
scared of the real man
i [ __ ] it till you love me [ __ ]
is he gay mike uh francois both are six
to one underdog
are there any concerns on your part i
don't know anything about that i don't
know nothing about numbers i just know
what i can do
how about kill this [ __ ] okay
how about the 19 months off what about
it
what about it does it pose any problem
to you
we'll see i doubt it seriously
you take into the ring a lot of rage
does that work for you or does it work
against you at times
you know who cares we're in a fight
anyway what what what does it matter
well for example rage against uh evander
holyfield worked against you
well [ __ ] it there's a fight so whatever
happens happened
mike why do you have to talk like that
well i'm talking to you the way i want
to talk to you
quite rude you have a problem turn off
your station
you know what he does not have manners
let me tell you that
in the discussion right now then we
could you got it
have a nice fight mike off
46 years old going to 36 i never dreamed
of living this long i never dreamed of
fornicating as many beautiful women as i
did i'm having as much money as i did i
won't talk nice to you and
talk about sonicating with you and
letting you suck my because
if i was eloquent with you you would
still look at me as a scumbag i may like
funny kid more than other people it's
just who i am i sacrificed so much with
my life
can i at least get laid you know me i've
been robbed of most of my money can i at
least get a [ __ ]
if i wish one of your guys had children
i've been right
oh my gosh if i could kick them in their
[ __ ] head or stomp on their testicles
before you could feel my pain because
that's the pain i have waking up every
day
are you talking all the time no i think
we're all talking together
i normally don't do anything with
women's unless i fornicate with them
so you shouldn't talk anymore unless you
wanna
what did you think in that first round
when he was moving trying to do an ali
with his left
i know when i when i came to this fight
i was the best fighter in the world now
man live that can beat me
what broke him down was it just body
punches
when i was hitting him with body parts
and i heard him actually he was crying
in there
making woman justice like oh oh i can't
find him but i knew that he was breaking
down soon you're saying that biggs was
crying when you
hit him yes when when did that happen
and
perhaps the fourth round on so that you
knew you had him by that absolutely but
i knew
he was tough and taking those punches
what's the opportunity because now i
know
there's no doubt in my mind that i'm
gonna take
razor erotic out you know i mean it's
good that he shows his heart that he's a
great fighter anyone to take me
but i guarantee you the florida even
being more slower
if you're um trying to intimidate
intimidate me in any way or whatsoever
don't you know that doesn't work didn't
you try it the first time so you don't
have to come out here and hack the same
ignorance you usually hack all the time
we're gonna fight any which way it goes
so just accept that and come in and do
the best you can
i dare you talk to me like that you
should you should get up and kneel to me
now and i'll spare you tonight at the
28th
the doctor said you come in and you come
ready you understand because i'm going
to come ready
okay okay you know i don't know why you
talk to me like that when you know i'll
kill you for it
that's what i like about you mike you
talk tough
mike tyson is mike tyson he's a huge
little kid you know what i mean and
he's going to be like that i don't want
to bring myself down to his level so i
don't really
want to cherish that card i'm going to
go in there and we're going to fight i
think
mike tyson just never like mentally got
past the age of like 15. bottom line
oh man i can't wait to the 28th i'm
going to make you my girlfriend
you say something hey yeah
because i want to bring myself down to
your level there's something you can't
buy in that class and you don't got none
of that
just sweet make sure you kiss me good
with those big lips
[Applause]
oh nasty stuff in there
he bite his ear it looked as if tyson
bared his teeth at one stage in the
exchange
yes all he feels
from that you see the blood on the ear
that was definitely a fight
what the is that legal
well feelings are running very
very hot indeed in there
holyfield was outraged by that oh my god
now what is the referee going to do
about that
[Applause]
that can't be legal for tyson it's here
now let's take a look again
[Applause]
it's just here he gets into the position
there watch
you see he steers there ah
what the [ __ ] there he bites him
i don't like that at that point trying
to rip free
and
well this is getting like a streak from
the second round which open the gash on
your eye tell us about that first period
um he butted me um in the first round
but then he butted me again in the
second round and as soon as he bought me
i watched him
he had me holding he looked right at me
and i saw him and he was going [ __ ]
he kept going flying he butted me again
he kept going down and coming up
and he charged into me and no one warned
him no one
took any points for him what am i to do
this is my career i can't continue
getting buddy like that
i got children to raise and this guy
keeps butting me trying to cut me and
getting stopped on cut
i got to retaliate now immediately you
stopped you stopped fighting immediately
right there and you turned to mills lane
and you said what
and he the result was he did nothing but
what did you say to mills right at that
time i don't remember what
i told him that he bought me but i know
i complained about being butted and we
go and we complain about the um the
first fight
listen holyfield's not the toughest
warrior one says he is
he got a little knicks on him there and
he quit i got it i got one eye
i got one eye he's not impaired he got
ears i got one i big that
he take one i got another one i'm ready
to fight he didn't want to fight i'm
ready to fight him right now mill's late
no mills lane stopped the fight it
wasn't holyfield he stopped oh he didn't
want to fight let me ask
we don't know what mill did nothing i
like how he's
justifying biting this man's ear mill
said he stopped the fight
you bit him was that a retaliation for
the eye
when you bit him in his ear regardless
of what i did he
bought me for two fights but you got to
address it mike
no i did address it i dressed it in the
ring
why did you do that though mike i mean
was that the proper response look at me
look at me look at me i got to go home
my kids are going to be scared of me
look at me man
what are you going to do now in terms of
your career mike will you continue
okay okay in terms did he get like
kicked out of fighting from this or i
don't know anything about mike tyson
extraordinary stuff there from mike
tyson
what happened at the end
[ __ ] kill you
it's kind of funny we had spoke earlier
today
can't define me i define my work as a
father i'm many things you know how many
things yeah i'm a convicted rapist
i'm i'm a i'm a hell raiser i'm a father
a loving father i'm a i'm you know i'm a
semi good husband
you know what i mean wait wait what
what you know i'm just a man out here
trying to enjoy my i was born poor i
ain't never had nothing i don't know how
to act all right
but the real thing is i'm just i'm just
here to be me i don't care about you you
know what i am
who are 23 anyone thinks i am um at this
stage of my life but um
yeah i'm a pretty much of a tyrant titan
yeah that's why
i'm listening right i don't know nothing
about being heavyweight champ i don't
know i know how to fight right i'm a
[ __ ] right
[ __ ] no really really really really i'm
not saying like i'm a black person and
i'll be i'm a street person i only want
to be a street person i don't even like
i don't even like typical street people
but that's just who i became and
what happened in my life and the
tragedies in life made me that way but
you know i'm like you know i'm not
malevolent or anything i just am
and i just want to just just live my
life and
i know you guys talk bad about me i got
a really
bad sneak by there about me but you're
going to make sure you talk about me
your grandkids and kids after that is
going to know about me
i want to make sure that they're never
going to forget about me the great
grandkids would say wow wasn't that a
bizarre individual
okay so let me get this straight how did
he say
convicted rapist and good husband
or semi-good husband in the same
sentence like what
this man is funny and nuts um let me
know in the comments if you guys are
mike tyson fans yes or no
do you think he's crazy or that's just
like how he is
do not forget to like comment and
subscribe
i will talk to you guys next time